in the fight against Ovid 19 researchers
need to know where it is and how it's
spreading what we're trying to do is to
improve the understanding of how the
kovat 19 pandemic is progressing across
England around the world researchers are
starting community transmission studies
to try and gather enough data to inform
public health policies but to get enough
data they need to find a way of testing
people at home don't eat or swallow any
part of the kit people like me got it
I'm Anna and today I'm going to be doing
an antibody test for kovat 19 I'm one of
the first guinea pigs for a home
antibody test being trialed here in the
UK so I'm involved in a study called
react and react stands for real-time
assessment of community transmission
Kristina HSN at Imperial College London
is part of the team behind the study
before rolling out a full-scale
community transmission study they need
to first figure out where the kits like
these are accurate and usable to test
for accuracy the team are comparing
self-administered results with proper
blood tests in the lab to test
reusability they've posted home test
kits to 10,000 randomly selected people
including me so what we're really trying
to understand here in in the usability
study is firstly whether people can and
perform the test at home okay and if not
what changes we can make to the tests or
instructions to improve people's ability
to carry out the test at home ah no no
no it's just going back up oh I've
sprayed blood everywhere no no okay got
it in and secondly can people read and
interpret the test results and if not
what changes can we make to the wording
and messaging to improve people's
ability to understand what the result
means for them antibody tests like this
aren't designed to tell me if I
currently have coded 19 but could tell
me if I've been infected before in this
case by testing for a type of antibody
called IgG so really what we're most
interested in is IgG as a marker as a
tantrum marker for long-term immunity
certainly in other infections it is a
mark of long-term immunity but as yet we
don't know if it is for covert 19
immunologists are still working to find
out whether having had the novel
coronavirus and having IgG antibodies in
your blood will in fact protect you from
catching it again in the future until
then my results aren't very much used to
me personally I'll still be observing
social distancing like everyone else but
for Christina and her team my data can
help get the home antibody testing kits
in top shape for the next round of tests
once we've optimized usability for home
testing then we plan to roll out the
tests to a hundred thousand randomly
selected people across England to assess
the prevalence of past infection in the
community in the meantime there's a lot
of work to do I've worked a lot weekends
over the last two or three months things
are changing all the time and unity
every other day and the news you hear
about another test via theist a new swab
test or a game-changing antibody test
people are very desperate and keen to
know when we're going to get back to
some level of the normality so with that
in mind with some whistle happy to serve
me working some twice as hard
[Music]